when she fell is mine come and see
you forsook
yo Rock mahak a son marry
I lisi for see every one of us is poor
and powerless and yet together
we can overthrow an empire
you
[Music]
hey youtubers it's Charlie so surprise
surprise HBO dropped a new teaser for
Game of Thrones Season 6 all about
Ramsay snow very pink letter if you've
read the books just careful for spoilers
for everything that's happened on the
show so far I'm going to do a quick
explainer for what the pink letter is
and what the show is going to change
about that because they will change some
stuff from the books the Daenerys teaser
is all about her conflict with the
Dothraki and Cal jaco is actually
speaking in Dothraki I'll explain that
after Ramsay Bolton pink letter stuff
and then the last teaser is actually the
high Sparrow versus Cersei so I'll
explain that too because it's all about
the faith militant there is a new round
of the give way to all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and leave a
comment on this video so the teaser
footage first what's going on is Ramsay
snow is basically just telling everyone
Winterfell is mine come and see you
could take this two ways he's speaking
to a specific person which is what I
kind of think is going on or two he's
speaking to the rest of the north anyone
that would challenge him now technically
you have to remember it's Roose Bolton
that holds Winterfell not Ramsay Bolton
but you saw how he bristle when he
thought that he was going to have a baby
brother that was legitimate that was
going to supersede him in the line of
succession so Ramsay's going to do
anything to preserve what he thinks is
his or is going to be his when his
father dies the minute Walden and Roose
announced the pregnancy I wonder of like
Ramsey is probably gonna try and abort
that baby remains to be seen though so
I'm just I'm waiting for it to happen
remember before Sansa's wedding when he
and Sansa were walking around the
battlements of Winterfell talking about
that she's like but but she wove a stud
and it just completely engaged Ramsay's
beast mode Ramsey's one of the most
terrible people but he makes some of the
best reaction faces so quick explainer
for the pink letter what what is going
on because that's kind of what I think
this teaser is it's like the show's
version of the pink letter it's
basically goading people or a specific
person to come to Winterfell into a
battle it's not just a statement it's a
challenge to anyone that would kick him
out of Winterfell now a version of this
happens in the books sallman explained
book five real quick because a lot has
changed from book five what happens is
is jon snow gets what is called the
bastard letter and it's signed by Ramsay
Bolton a lot of people think that
someone else wrote it to go Jon Snow
into a battle with Ramsay Bolton to
take care of the Bolton's for whoever
wrote it because remember in the books
before you know before the big for the
watch moment when the watch assassinates
John he's bound to his oath so unless it
were in service to the wall he's not
gonna go anywhere he's not gonna leave
the wall so someone is trying to push
jon snow over the edge with this crazy
letter that's supposedly written by
Ramsay Bolton so I'm gonna read the
letter real quick here it's pretty cool
this is from book 5 so here we go your
false king is dead bastard he and all
his hosts were smashed in seven days of
battle I have his magic sword tell his
red [ __ ] your false Kings friends are
dead their heads upon the walls of
Winterfell come see them bastard your
false King lied and so did you you told
the world you burn the
king-beyond-the-wall instead you sent
him to Winterfell to steal my bride from
me I will have my bride back if you want
Mance Rayder back come and get him I
have him in a cage for all the north to
see proof of your lies the cage is cold
but I've made him a warm cloak from the
skins of the six horse who came with him
to Winterfell I want my bride back I
want the false Kings queen I want his
daughter and his red which I want this
wildling princess I want his little
prince the wildling babe and I want my
reek send them to me bastard and I will
not trouble you or your black crows keep
them from me and I will cut out your
bastards heart and eat it signed Ramsay
Bolton trueborn Lord of Winterfell so
already you can see the circumstances
with which this letter is sent and some
of the things that describes have
happened on the show but in the books is
a little bit different it's kind of a
bluff like Ramsey lies about having
defeated Stannis even though Stannis has
already been defeated on the show so
whatever version of this letter gets
sent out it's going to be a little bit
different but in the line that talks
about bringing his reek and his bride
back there there's a fake arya that they
substituted Sansa for on the show in the
books Ramsey suffers a couple slides but
he's still entrenched in Winterfell in
Santa's has his army nearby so it's like
they're preparing for the Battle of
Winterfell even though that kind of
already happened on the show like a
version of that stan has tried and
failed so the idea is is that the true
battle for winter
felda preparing for in the books is
something that might do in the show the
idea is is that Jon Snow would take
brothers from the Nights Watch the
wildling army and match them with
Stannis's forces to defeat the Bolton's
now that's just in the books so it seems
like the show is teasing a version of
that but it could change in a number of
different ways in there have been some
spoilers from the set so if you want to
talk about those just please use spoiler
tags my big question is are we going to
see an actual version of the pink letter
on the show like a physical letter that
is sent to the wall before the show
changed a couple things there were a lot
of theories about who actually sent the
pink letter but people thought that it
was like a false letter sent by someone
else to go Jon Snow to take the Wild
links to Winterfell the TV show has
already killed one of the prime
candidates a lot of people think that
Mance Rayder wrote the letter like he
wanted Jon Snow to get rid of Ramsay
Bolton and he didn't think that Jon Snow
would do it on his own so he's like okay
I'll write this crazy letter make Jon
Snow think that Ramsay has his sister
now in the books instead of Sansa
winding up marrying Ramsay it's actually
a fake version of Arya Stark that they
masquerade as Arya Stark like nobody's
seen Arya they won't know it's not her
so it ends up being Santa's friend Jane
pool from King's Landing we haven't
actually seen on the show for a while
but on the show fake arya of the books
become Sansa Stark so there are some
similarities but the way it goes down is
going to be very different if they do
end up doing this let me know in the
comments though do you think that this
teaser is them saying yeah we're totally
going to do the pink letter now
obviously a couple things have to happen
before they can accomplish that just
speculation certain character coming
back before he can receive said letter
and they could just have Ramsay sent
several copies to all the Lords of the
North but I think it'll be a little bit
closer to the books at least in spirit
it's not an exact match for what goes
down it's going to be awesome and if you
want to reread that part of the books
just reread book five moving on to the
Daenerys teaser so obviously at the end
of season five she was captured by the
khalasar that belongs to Cal Jacko he
actually swallowed a lot of Cal Drago's
forces after they abandoned when he died
early in season one remember Cal Drago
had this massive khalasar so when she
got crazy with the blood magic a lot of
them bolted and got swallowed up by
other callous
Cal Jacko's just like the next biggest
guy to come along so it sounds like he
doesn't give a [ __ ] about donairs or the
fact that she's a Targaryen about about
her heritage or her dragons so either
she's gonna have to defeat them in
battle or win them over somehow but I
just can't wait it's going to be this
awesome big battle so it's not like
everybody in the East just rolls over
for generics when she comes along now
and moving on to the high Sparrow teaser
this is high Sparrow versus sir see you
know even if you thought the walk of
shame was the end of their battle that
is just the beginning for the high
Sparrow in the faith he talks about the
disenfranchised banding together
becoming this great force that's the
faith militant they're actually a
historical organization that was banned
by the crown a long time ago but Cersei
allowed them to be reinstated so she
inadvertently is creating this new
problem for herself now I've already
done a video about the faith militant so
I put a link in the description but this
is the major conflict of King's Landing
but it's actually much bigger than that
for the faith militant because King's
Landing isn't the only place where there
is inequality between the rich and the
poor soul add enough time this movement
that the high Sparrow is trying to
create in the poor the disenfranchised
will spread across Westeros that mean
that that sounds like the idea based on
what he's saying HBO's actually been
dropping a bunch of these short teaser
so I'm guessing that we might see one or
two more before we see the first like
official teaser trailer with a bunch of
footage from season six they dropped it
in February last year I don't know if
they're going to tie it to a specific
event no matter what happens no worries
I will totally do a video for it so now
our trailer watch begins and
congratulations to this week's giveaway
winner Road nemesis you and a twenty
dollar amazon gift card just be sure to
private message me on the back end of my
channel so i can get your contact
details there is a new Deadpool video
that I'm working on for later tonight so
that should post in the next couple of
hours i'll try to get chimichangas out
as soon as possible happy friday you
thought friday was boring you haven't
been paying attention just in case you
guys haven't seen it there been a couple
teasers already for season six you can
click here to watch all of them and you
can click here for last night's legends
of tomorrow up so thank you so much
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tonight
[Music]
you